all right now at this point you have a
choice you have a choice
this is a vigorous the numbers are
because but the facts is fun okay what I
can do is let's just do this move st.
Margaret if I had this as an equation
not as an inequality if I had this for a
brief moment try to ignore see through
see past the disgustingness of the
numbers how would you rewrite that
equation in order to solve for M okay
now it's interesting that it's not the
main way I would have gone to it first I
will show you that method in a minute
but I'm actually just going to say like
this is an exponential like two to the
five equals thirty-two is an exponential
so I would write that as 5 it was long
2:32 do you agree with that
like that's just that's just a straight
definition of one more gears okay so
therefore here I could write that as
long now what's the base yeah you always
do the base first because the base here
will be the base of the line so it's one
point zero zero five and then I had this
awkward-looking fraction up here okay so
yes
okay okay now that's one thing I could
do however yes I do not have an equation
I got an inequality now pause for a
moment I want you to go right back to
the beginning of the question right now
what are we trying to do we're trying to
find at what point in the repayments at
what point do I hit a threshold it's
like cool I passed the halfway mark okay
I passed the halfway mark if I have to
pass a halfway mark and then anywhere
after that like the numbers only gonna
get smaller right is it going to be
greater than this number or less than
this number think about it I want to
know all of the number of months such
that the amount that your handle is
smaller and smaller and smaller clearly
I want to go into the future no time
right if n were like say the number was
150 which it's not that's the halfway
point there's some people guess believe
I'm not some people just write down 150
and then make their heard
suppose 150 all right in that case 151
would be okay wouldn't it 152 would also
be okay all of the subsequent months the
numbers should be getting smaller right
so that's the first way you can say more
clearly just by logic of the question
clearly it has to be right up that's the
first way you do matters here's another
way come back to this again look at this
line right one point zero zero five to
the N
yes some of them at a time you can get
the graphs of exponential curves
what is that exponential effect what do
all expenditures the five right it looks
like this right and you want a point you
want to point where this thing is
greater than a certain value right so
like I have no idea when that number is
two eight three nine
somewhere like here right 139 so I want
all the parts of this curve that are
above like that so which way is he gonna
call it the base answer since it's up
what corresponds to that is and is
greater than whatever that number is
okay it has to be greater than
absolutely must be positive okay what am
I going to do to evaluate this is my
calculator changes back yeah change of a
sports so I'm gonna go and he's greater
than and you choose whatever face you
like I'm just gonna right now let me
because I'm lazy
it is the least number of letters I can
use to indicate a long right you can do
that and you get a number out okay now
just before we get that number out I
want to show you because this that's not
the only way you can go about this
sorting out this direction of the
inequality okay
let me show you is one of the way you
could use come back to this line yeah
what I can do is write if you got some
number and it's bigger than some other
number write clean even longer this
number is bigger than the water that
number as well right
does that make sense like it's how long
it takes to Cory bear right to the
timeless people so if this number bigger
than this then log of that number must
also being bigger than log of that
number do you agree with that statement
right you have some number like 10 its
sorry number like 100 which is greater
than 10 log 100 is bigger than 110 give
me that but look just by saying that
I've avoided this whole problem of
working out rich weight is my inequality
good because look at this I use my lawn
mowers to bring that and at the front
you see that's just throwing out the
front and then over here I just need to
isolate that end so I divide through by
log of 1 point ears here at 5 now what's
a little more prettier so is it is it
negative it's gotta be positive because
look it's getting bigger right so
therefore when I divide through by that
number then the sign doesn't change
right and wait a second that looks
familiar doesn't it right so if you
prefer not to read yourself out with
like wait which way to face or like a
thing like if that just makes you hurt
then just take logs of both sides not
the normal way the normal part that most
people take
most people take this path but as a
result get confused I think it's worth
knowing how to do it this way and you
think about it but if in a pinch you can
use that ok so I was thinking about this
graph here
right and I know every exponential more
or less looks the same they all look
like this okay so I want this graph to
be above a certain value like is a value
and I want to be above it the N value
you sees that announces the correspond
to that ah through the right you see
that these values to the right
correspond to these values up because
they're this pond
okay so you just need to pay attention
to what this number is
now think about for instance if um if I
had something and we'll look at these
later on if I had something that was
shrieking instead of growing right then
this is Mel McKee it might be something
like I tonight all good one
I'm sorry 0.92 the end now he's a thing
when I when I bring that in out the
front this is good and then when I
divide through by log of 0.9
you put long as you're putting on your
calculator I don't know what it is but
it's negative right because log of 1 log
of 1 is 0 that's the switch other point
right that's why this is just so that's
why in some ways you've got to watch out
for the side regardless but like for
these financial pressures you're pretty
much always looking at interest rates
that grow because that's what interest
rates do okay now I'm gonna get I
haven't said the number what is the
number give me a decimal so the original
question was what month is it
then I took past and get less than
imagining has not going and that month
he is - OH - you've got to get past that
one even this was 201 point one I need
to get past that I need to get past the
threshold now by the way how many months
were there in total again 300 so you've
got to get 2/3 the way through the life
of the loan before you pay off half of
the work that's because at the beginning
you've got all of this huge amount of
learning interest so even though you're
putting all of these repayment in
they're not making much of a dent the
interest is almost as big as this so
that's the way money in interest works
that's the percentages